pas là on a effectivement fait affaire
avec le diable matthieu aron c'est très
compliqué cette affaire parce que bien
évidemment on ne peut qu'être choqué
quand on a vu les images de cnn
on ne peut être que choqué quand on sait
effectivement par un certain nombre de
reportages et même par des rapports
officiels ce qui se passe en libye ce
trafic
mais en même temps on sait qu'au moment
où cet été ce souci qui était à nouveau
ce est arrivé assez massive de migrants
non plus en grèce mais en italie
soudainement soudainement effectivement
ces arrivées ont cessé ont diminué de 10
femmes été divisé par dix en un mois
pourquoi parce que le gouvernement
italien a passé semble-t-il des accords
avec un certain nombre de trafiquants
libyen et c'est toute la difficulté
quinqua l'europe c'est bon on pourrait
dénoncé une hypocrisie européenne en dix
ans ou même de celle de maquereaux
endéans voilà il ya il parle de crimes
contre l'humanité mais en même temps il
est certes sauf que non la situation
elle est horriblement complexe
horriblement complexe
on aimerait en tant qu'être humain
effectivement accueillir et en même
temps on fait tous les risques qui
existent alors il nous arrive ces images
on connaît la situation et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait donc vraiment c'est vraiment
complexe et d'histoire